sur la nature de la de la présence en
Afrique de choses il y a ce débat sur le
maintien d'une présence d'une présence
militaire c'est-à-dire que le reproche
et qu'il faut entendre qui est fait
c'est que la présence militaire
française d'ailleurs qui se fait dans
des zones qui sont les moins importantes
pour notre commerce extérieur en termes
de pourcentage je le je le souligne
aussi a été vu par les élites locales ou
par les populations locales comme trop
militariser c'est-à-dire que la présence
de l'uniforme du régalien extérieur
probablement été trop devenu trop
visible c'est c'est un élément à mon
avis à apprendre en compte et le
deuxième élément c'est que moi je suis
assez perplexe sur l'idée de vouloir
faire de l'influence sans présence
et donc je pense que le débat sur la
présence en Afrique mérite probablement
nécessaire de l'adapter compte tenu de
cette évolution des sociétés africaines
et de cette impression de rejet que vous
évoquiez que je partage
mais là aussi je pense qu'il faut pas
forcément
se précis se précipiter et peut-être
essayer de réfléchir à d'autres
modalités présentes c'est aussi comme ça
que j'ai lu les dernières interventions
présidentielles